talking about like transport in london i
guess like i i guess like there has been
like a talk of the town since uh since
we got here uh because everyone like
that i've hung out with can't stop
talking about this [ __ ] elizabeth
line that's just [ __ ] opened up yeah
i like heard about it and it's like some
like fancy new line that's like recently
opened up yeah yeah so apparently it's
this it's this line that's been planned
for like that was meant to open i
believe in like oh many years ago yeah
yeah like like 2020 i believe nothing
that's open nothing in the uk yeah never
gets done on time yeah
and then it got it got delayed it got
delayed but like the hype was real i
thought like i come into london coming
to a convention people be like oh have
you started watching spike's family are
you watching any new anime no everyone's
like yo you've been on the elizabeth
line have you been on the elizabeth line
like
i haven't i i haven't yet i haven't and
i i swear to god someone could just like
have given birth the day before i'd be
like baby nah bruh elizabeth line that's
the real hype man i gotta try my i gotta
travel real stuff yeah yeah yeah but
like from what i heard it's just like
it's a air-conditioned line and i'm just
like isn't that just every train in
japan
and she did
it's like the the series of questions we
got were very different to how the the
the list of questions i would normally
get at a signing right because like
before trash days it was always like
what do you think about this anime what
do you think about this manga and there
was like definitely like you know some
amounts of those yeah but i think the
top three questions i received
during that entire weekend was yeah
number one was have you had a tesco meal
deal yet number two was have you been to
greggs yet yes and number three was have
you been to spoons yet
like
nothing to do with anime it was all just
like have you had these things yeah have
you had any of them well yeah you took
me to a spoon the last time i was here
but apparently he took me to like the
worst it was the worst
yeah but no i i still haven't had the
tesco meal doing i really wanted greg's
i haven't had a great year at all so uh
i mean yeah we're here for a little bit
i've forgotten how passionate people are
about greg's yeah it's very good greg's
is the bakery yes the bakery yeah yeah
so much more than that though yeah it is
it's it's an experience
you know i'm just a baker yeah yeah like
i feel like you have to go there at
least once to get your british passport
you know that's that's the last test
like
because it's it's really weird because i
didn't realize how
unknown greg's was to people outside of
england right
because you know we a lot of people
british people we speak about nando's we
speak about spoons but like not a lot of
people speak about greg's abroad and
it's just one of these british things
that if you're in england you you would
have been to a greg's at least once in
your life you might not always talk
about it but it's part of being british
right right and i didn't realize this
until i came back to england and uh and
you know everyone started asking me if
i'd gone to like if i'd gone back to
greg's year you know
it's important greg's important thing i
feel yeah from from what i heard from
people like i feel
being british person and not going to
graze is like being a japanese person
and not going to family mod
it's like it's like that level of like
but
you know to me like family it's he's
even more than family mart because you
can find family mart all over asia it's
it's it's like it's like all over asia
so greg i didn't know that yeah yeah
there's like family mods in thailand
actually
i don't know either news to me yeah yeah
yeah exactly so it's it's not like a
specific chat it's it's obviously very
japanese was like i'm gonna assume it
started in japan but it's like expanded
but like i believe greg's is only
available in the uk right and it's it's
nothing
so there's like a real like british
prize yeah yeah so it's cheap it tastes
amazing um yeah what's next sausage
rolls man
have you guys like hyped it up but like
literally every second british person i
met this weekend is like greg's though
the nearest greg's yeah real [ __ ]
yeah get get your boy some greg's and
then there were people being like yo so
like have you been at tesco's yet like
have you had the tesco meal deal yeah
like not yet and i knew like it was like
real [ __ ] because like people were like
all right here's my recommendation these
are the ones to avoid these are the ones
that you should go for and i i didn't
realize there were so many different
meal deals and like there were people
like in the signing right there would be
like a person in front of me being like
all right so here's the meal deal i
recommend and i knew it was real [ __ ]
when like the person behind them would
like interject and be like no no no no
no
don't don't don't don't give me don't
spread misinformation yeah yeah yeah
this is the real [ __ ] and i was just
like guys chill out
that's it there's a greg 10 minutes away
from him [ __ ] yeah
but yeah i mean like i mean like we talk
about tesco meal deals but a meal deal
is like a lot of choice so you need to
like have the optimal order right yeah i
mean there's just like there's like it's
it's like blackjack this is the perfect
way to play it you know that's what a
meal deal is right so you need to you
need to learn how to count cards okay
pick the right meal deal because you
know there's certain items in the meal
deal that you can get where if you were
to buy them individually it would cost
like two pound fifty right so you can
kind of min max the price options right
yeah so don't be buying water don't get
like you know uh [ __ ] little fruit
thing get maximize your your cost
performance yeah you don't wanna go for
walkers crisps mccoy's crisps the big
boys as well or the mess or walkers max
walker's man you can't just go like the
little [ __ ] basic ass vanilla you get
like an innocent smoothie as well then
i'm like two pounds
every person at the same time
it's important i knew it was real [ __ ]
as well because there was like a bunch
of people also like when they mentioned
the tesco meal deal they were like they
came up to me and they were like yeah
you know tesco meal deals are amazing
but they upped it by 50p and it's an
absolute [ __ ] travesty and i'm just
like i wish i could feel your anger
right now because it seems very real
right there's one like one minute walk
not even one minute like it's literally
opposite our hotel oh [ __ ] yeah so yeah
yeah there's usually there was this
article in the uk uh that some doctor
was calling for meal deals to be banned
because they're too unhealthy really and
they're too like
appealing yeah because they're still
feeling because people people just buy
these for like every day for lunch
because it's such good value for money
and they taste [ __ ] amazing right but
they're really bad for you
because the sandwiches are like
absolutely like
just stuffed with awful stuff yeah yeah
but it's like a mcdonald's burger it's
like you don't want to know what goes in
but you know it tastes sometimes it
tastes good right yeah why does it taste
so damn good what does ronald put in
those are exactly the same as all right
oh yeah like you know the sandwiches are
like not fresh at all but like yeah but
they still taste good it tastes really
funny yeah i mean i guess it's like
talking going back to like why people
are recommending you what to order it's
kind of like going to like you know a
chinese dress from here ordering like
kung pao chicken or something like i've
had chinese food and then you know
everyone would be like no you have not
had chinese food you know and i mean
it's like panda express yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly
yeah
no
like i'm not even the meal deal guy but
if you go if you're gonna try one out
joey at least try like the optimal meal
deal
and then we can have a real experience
and then we can argue about it you know
yeah
some of the sandwiches come with an
additional slice oh just for free like
just out of the general it's not like a
secret menu or anything no no no no
there's like because normally it's like
you don't have to say like a code word
normally it's like two slices but some
of them for some reason they have like
one sandwich and a half in it and no one
knows why
it's one of the great mysteries of the
world it's like they're like just trying
to figure it out if you've like truly
optimized it yeah like if you're if
you're a real player yeah i don't know
that's how you've gone through like
everything in the menu you know so you
so you you know the good [ __ ] i've had
i've had a pot noodle yet [ __ ] i want to
have a bombay bad boy partner is that
like the
cup noodle there yeah
dude the spicy one is so good it's so so
good well i'd see i want to experience
this all right all right yeah i guess i
guess i guess i'm just i'm just scared
that you might not like the stuff and
i'll be like this is literally my entire
existence is waiting on this like if you
don't if you don't if you don't like
this i'm gonna die
i mean look there's a lot of food that
is considered awful that i absolutely
enjoy so i mean how bad are you going
famous last words how bad could it be
you gotta be honest joey you gotta be
honest you know we wouldn't be the trash
taste podcast if we weren't honest i
keep forgetting how [ __ ] mayo is as well
huh i keep forgetting how bad yeah i've
i've gone back to not eating mayo i i i
had one sandwich because like japan has
conditioned me to being like mayo tastes
good
yeah
i always forget i'm just like i just
assume everywhere has cute mayonnaise
yeah it's like oh no that that was like
a delicacy should have brought your own
that's like some real [ __ ] yeah yeah i
i've kind of like come to this
realization because i did like i did
it's a small tangent but before the boys
came here i did go on like uh
go on like a
quick trip to like belgium
um and i ate
a lot of bread oh oh i i i ate a lot of
i'm awake now basically every [ __ ]
meal i ordered the meal and i'd get a
loaf of bread and it wasn't like the
same like
a little bun no no i'm not talking about
that it's like loaf i think they they
basically gave me half a like wow every
i swear to god every [ __ ] meal like
even if it wasn't a meal even if i
ordered a drink with like some quick
snacks and that they just give you bread
dude belgium belgium knows what's up
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah so like brett
i think i like bread
that's character development right there
i i
i want to do a proper like bread tasting
stream or something like actually try
proper bread because like i i kind of
realized that maybe my entire life i
didn't have [ __ ] taste maybe my entire
life i just grew up in a place that i
just had [ __ ] food yes
there's that [ __ ] bread [ __ ] you know
you can get good bread in the uk you
just didn't see each other you just need
to like seek it out where it's just like
it's it you know you have to go to like
specialty places it's so good though
which is like which is like true for a
lot of like cuisine in the uk which is
like you can't get good stuff here what
you just have to seek wait so what's
your favorite bread now
like your favorite kind i don't know i
don't know i just tried a lot of bread
and they all tasted amazing i i i need
to get more in i i need to get more uh
[ __ ]
bread man i just i'm just like i just
got given bread i'm like i want bread my
man's finally getting that bread
give you bread and they give you like a
little [ __ ] uh olive oil kind of dip
thing with like yeah i like the balsamic
oh don't mind if i do yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
i love bread so much every time i go to
like an italian restaurant in the states
think you like that bread with the olive
oil and the balsamic i'm like [ __ ] the
pasta just give me more of this [ __ ]
it's sort of good
i think spending money in england is way
too easy
bro yeah just tapping that card yeah
it's like monopoly so like i know the
u.s has contact list japan has
contactless but like
in the form of suica no no one you can't
use it like restaurants and stuff right
it's it's for like other places yeah it
is getting better though too yeah yeah
because like a lot of i did notice that
a lot of places because like in
australia as well now it's like
everything is just like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i mean like in the uk now it just seems
to be that like the default is now the
tapping the credit card yeah yeah and
it's way too easy to spend a lot of
money yeah yeah
something pops up you're like i don't
even know how much it is [ __ ] tap and
then you're like i'm broke now [ __ ]
because like i remember like the the
first time like they they bring that out
right and they just kind of like hand it
to you it's like
i was because i'm so used to doing it in
japan right so i pulled my phone out
like get my suitca ready right and i was
just like nope that's not it that's it's
credit cards credit card i think you
could do with your phone though if you
had the right things yeah right and it's
like and and because you know i'm so
used to like even in japan when you do
like the whole tapping thing yeah like
not only can you see how much money
you've spent but it's also like there's
a little bit of a process right yeah
like you know kind of get it going but
yeah in the uk it's literally just
and you're done yeah yeah because
because a lot of the times uh because
with contactless here they like it's
they have like a specific device for
contactless or they'll they'll like show
you the side with the contactless on
yeah uh and it's not decided with the
price on so you don't even know how much
is good yeah exactly exactly like i i've
realized after coming back this time
they've increased the limit again yeah
when first contactless started coming
out i believe the limit was like 20 when
it when when i was at 20.
and then it got really increased to 30
and then i believe 40. and i was like
80. we we just [ __ ] doubled the
amount with a single tap of your card
you can spend a hundred bucks you know
that's so scary
like
i realized how dangerous this was
because at the convention uh i was like
buying i was like buying a round of
drinks um
and uh i didn't like i normally in japan
they at least they tell you the price
right they tell you the price of how
much you're spending and here they don't
even tell you the price they just assume
you know the price and they they they
give you the contact thing and you beep
it so i i bring back i bring about the
drinks and i remember one of my friends
asked me oh was uh are the drinks
expensive here and i would just go
yeah i didn't know
maybe
so i feel like yes is the answer but i
don't know yeah and i know like uh
i say i think it's probably expensive i
know and they were like no no is it
london expensive or is it london hotel
expensive and i was just like
yes yes
yes either one of those yeah
um i probably have to ask how much
drinks are but right now i literally
have no idea i just tapped my wallet
away i literally don't know how much
i've spent while i've been here just
because again they don't tell you yeah
it's so easy it's literally just like
throwing monopoly money out true true
being like yeah cool okay that was easy
sweet and then it's only when you get
back to the hotel and you're like oh
[ __ ] i wish it was monopoly money
because at least with monopoly money you
kind of like know how much you're
spending you're like you know i keep
tracking my monopoly money
i spend it very carefully
yeah because that's scary i remember
like um
because we went to we we we had a night
and we ended up just like quickly just
like as a group mates in the casino
right and so
uh we didn't you know we didn't play
that much but you know i played a little
bit and i ended up with some some like
physical money on me at the end of the
night right and i remember like cashing
out getting this physical money in my
wallet and i was like this is useless
when am i ever going to spend this when
am i ever going to spend this physical
money that they've given me right and
because you don't ever need to spend
like cash at all yeah i noticed yeah
yeah so now it's just like a paperweight
in my [ __ ] wallet
suffering from success
it's not even it's like what am i going
to do with all this money this is just
suffering from convenience
it is suffering from convenience that
we've gotten to now oh my god